hi honor you made history you got to  ring in the ring out ring out ring out  you labelled and at the stock in the jab  they let you be the guy who hits the  gavel that's the end of the training at  Wall Street and you got a little  overzealous with the mallet let's take a  look yeah it's amazing it's the New York  Stock Exchange but they have this cheap  mallet and anyway the rule is you break  it you buy it so I have it looked like a  really expensive mallet yeah at least  we're gonna do that yours was memorable  yes I don't they said for some reason  they knew and it happened on this was  the third time in the history of the  Stock Exchange that it had had broken  that's really yeah I don't know how they  knew that fun fact yeah he did only the  third time good for you the other guy  was Hulk Hogan well Medal of Honor  winner actually was the other guy I  forgot  you